hi I'm Chet Haase an engineer in the
Android team at Google
I work on graphics and animation stuff
and today I wanted to talk about the
topic of bitmaps in particular I want to
talk about bitmaps and garbage first a
history lesson might help prior to the
3.0 release we managed bitmap memory at
the Native level the VM knew about it
but it really didn't manage it and you
in your application were responsible for
calling recycle to very actively manage
that when you're done with bitmap you
call recycle that gets rid of the memory
otherwise you may run out of enough
memory enough native memory to allocate
another bitmap so this is a very careful
things that think that applications
needed to manage very tightly we decided
that it would be a little bit better for
everyone if we actually manage that for
you and we brought the bitmap memory
back into the VM along with the rest of
the memory that the garbage collector
manages so now when you allocate memory
for a bitmap we allocate it on the
virtual machine heap and then we know
when references to that memory are gone
so that we can collect it appropriately
in particular when a reference to a
large bitmap goes away and you want to
allocate another bitmap then we can see
that while there's no reference to this
other one there we can collect it in
order to make room for the new one that
needs to come into the heap at that time
so all of this is great except that it
gets into situations where maybe the GC
is going to be triggered more than it
was before because you're not managing
your own memory manually instead we are
managing that memory for you and we
manage memory by having the garbage
collector kick in and collect things
when it needs to if there's not a memory
in the heap we'll collect stuff that
needs to be collected including large
bitmaps now the trick to this is that
large amounts of memory can be more
expensive to collect and large heaps are
more expensive to collect so if there's
large pieces of memory due to bitmaps
constantly churning through the system
then you're we're going to be collecting
memory for them a lot right if you're
constantly like on every frame I saw an
application like this recently where on
every frame of every animation
they were loading a new bitmap and
getting rid of the old one and in the
old system they would actively manage
this and call recycle and the other one
would be loaded in place and and life
was good but as of 3.0 that meant that
the old one was on the heap the new one
wanted to be on the heap there wasn't
enough room for the both of them and so
it needed to collect from the first one
relatively expensive garbage collection
to then load in the second one next
frame around same thing needs to collect
the old one to make enough room for the
new one
now that's a reality of dealing with
memory management garbage collectors and
it's it's decent enough but there's
actually a really good way that you can
work around that problem and in
particular if you're working with
bitmaps that are exactly the same size
which this particular application was
then you can actually reuse bitmaps so
you can have one bitmap that everything
gets loaded into along the way and save
yourself some serious garbage collection
and performance along the way so let's
take a look at a quick demo I call this
demo bitmap allocation and it's a
picture viewer I have some pictures that
I've loaded up in the background and we
can click through these and see these
other images and each one of these
images is getting loaded on the fly as
we go through that just for the purposes
of this demo and then I print out the
number of milliseconds that it took to
load each of these images up at the top
so these loads took 290 326 304 340 320
so a little non-deterministic based on
you know what else is going on in the
system and how long GC is took and stuff
like that
now if we reuse the bitmap then again
this is a little bit hard to see because
the numbers can be a little bit erratic
but what I see in runs that I've done at
least on other devices is a savings of
in general about 10 to 20 percent which
is not bad if you're talking about 300
milliseconds interframe saving 30
milliseconds is a big deal now ideally
you'd actually find a better way to load
these images than loading them on the
fly when you're ready to draw them
that's not the best way to go about it
but the the point of this demo is more
to show the raw amount of time that it
might take to load these things and a
lot of that is the garbage collection so
let's take a quick look before we look
at the code we can take a look at a log
that I ran right before this where I was
what happened before and after I checked
that little box that said we use the bid
map and here's what we get let's see
here's what we got before I check the
box is nothing right this this was the
output not the GC output above but this
output here is what we saw when we reuse
the bitmap but when we're not reusing
the bitmap this is what we see right on
every frame we're incurring potentially
very expensive garbage collections some
of that runs in parallel but we still
have pauses of 21 milliseconds for Alex
3 milliseconds here 12 milliseconds
there if you imagine that a 60 frame per
second application only has 16
milliseconds in order to draw each frame
these numbers are huge you really want
to avoid them if you can so how do we do
that
we use bitmap factory options so let's
go in here take a look at the code this
is the bitmap application code and here
we have the checkbox that determines
whether we're actually going to do reuse
or not and in here we're going to create
our bitmap that gets reused on the fly
so first of all we're going to decode
the initial image that we start with
this application does assume that all
the bitmaps are the same size and this
is a restriction with reusing the
bitmaps with this API is that it will
only work for bitmaps of the same size
so we get the size of the initial bitmap
and we get only the size we don't force
it to actually load that bitmap yet by
using the in just decode Bowden options
and that will return the width and the
height that we can then use in our
create bitmap call so we use the the
width and the height that we need to
sort of get this sandbox we're going to
load all these things into then we reset
that flag and we set the in bitmap flag
and that is the new API that was
introduced in 3.0 at the same time as
the other change to the memory
management of bitmaps and we set that
equal to this sandbox bitmap that we've
just created and then we set the in
sample size to 1 and this is unnecessary
an unfortunate bug that got fixed in a
recent release where if you didn't set
the sample size it wouldn't do the right
thing so
do need to set it to what would be the
default option in sample size of one and
then we decode the resource and away we
go so now we're in our click listener
every time you click on the image we're
going to load in the next image and
we're either going to reuse that bitmap
or we're not so if the checkbox is
checked we're going to reuse the bitmap
and we're going to do that by saying the
bitmap options equals these options that
we've created above which has this in
bitmap parameter set in it which tells
it's a trigger to the code to say okay
this is the sandbox where I'm going to
actually load this new bitmap into and
so we set the in bitmap flag there and
then I was just issuing some timing
because this is how I produce the the
times that are spit out in the UI so we
can see how long these things take
we then decode the resource and that
will either reuse the bitmap or not
depending on whether we set the in
bitmap parameter above and then we set
the new image bitmap in the image view
finally we get the final time that it
took and display that in the UI and
that's it not very hard to use but
definitely worth using especially if
you're in the case where you're
constantly loading in new bitmaps and
those bitmaps are the same size as other
bitmaps that you're now done with this
basically allows a garbage collector to
get out of the way because there's
nothing to collect if you're loading the
new bitmap into the place of the old one
so check out bitmap options in
particular in bitmap and save some grief
over garbage collection times thanks